El profesor le advirtió que no fuese al baño de los chicos.
Un día se bebió dos vasos de ese zumo de color rojo
en la fiesta de Halloween.
¿Quién es capaz de resistirse? Ese zumo rojo es muy rico.
No se podía aguantar el pipí mucho más.
Ella y sus compañeros tenían cuatro años.
Sus compañeros ya creían tener la potestad de controlar
el uso que esta niña podría hacer de los denominados baños públicos.
Era una niña de cuatro años.
Ya le habían dado una lección brutal:
no había ningún baño en su jardín de infancia
que tuviese una señal que diese la bienvenida a personas como ella.
Acababa de aprender que el cuarto de baño sería un problema.
Un problema que sería de ella
y solo para ella.
Mi amiga me pidió que hablase con la niña
y hablé con ella.
Quería decirle
que su madre y yo íbamos a hablar con su colegio
para solucionar el problema.
Pero yo sabía que no era verdad.
Quería decirle que todo sería más fácil cuando creciese,
pero tampoco podía.
Le pedí que me contase lo que había ocurrido
y le pedí que me contase cómo se sentía.
"Enfadada y triste",
me dijo.
Y le dije
que no estaba sola
y que lo que le había pasado no estaba bien.
Me preguntó que si alguna vez me había hecho pipí encima.
Le dije que sí,
pero no por mucho tiempo.
(Risas)
También es mentira,
porque ya saben que cuando se cumplen los 40,
a veces se escapa el pipí
al toser o al estornudar
al subir las escaleras o al hacer estiramientos.
No digan mentiras.
Esto ocurre, ¿verdad?
No creo que a esta niña le haga falta saber estas cosas.
(Risas)
Le dije que, cuando crecemos, la vejiga también crece.
"Cuando crezcas como yo,
podrás aguantarte el pipí más tiempo".
Se lo prometí.
"¿Hasta llegar a casa?",
me preguntó.
Le dije que sí.
"Sí, hasta llegar a casa".
Y, al parecer, eso la consoló en parte.
¿Por qué no instalamos baños unisex y unipersonales
con un pequeño banco para cambiarse de ropa para educación física?
No podemos cambiar el mundo de la noche a la mañana
para nuestros hijos,
pero podemos darles un lugar íntimo y seguro
para refugiarse de ese mundo,
aunque solo sea por unos minutos.
Podemos hacerlo.
Hagámoslo.
Si alguno de Uds. ya está pensando
en una lista de razones por las que este asunto no es prioritario
o que es demasiado caro
o que le niegue a una persona transexual un espacio seguro donde ir al baño
o cambiarse de ropa,
Uds. apoyan la elección de un estilo de vida que ofende sus valores
o su masculinidad
o sus creencias religiosas.
Déjeme apelarles
a esa parte de sus corazones que, probablemente, se preocupe
por el resto de la población.
¿Si a Ud. no le importa el bienestar de gente como yo,
qué me dice de esas mujeres y niñas
con problemas de imagen?
¿Qué me dice de alguien que tenga problemas de percepción de su imagen?
¿Qué pasa con el chico que es el bajito de su clase
y al que todavía no le ha cambiado la voz?
Ay, la adolescencia en la escuela,
qué cruel puede llegar a ser.
¿Verdad?
¿Qué me dicen de las personas con problemas de ansiedad,
de las personas con discapacidades que necesitan atención en esos lugares?
¿Qué me dicen de la gente cuyo cuerpo, por algún motivo,
no encaja con los cánones que dictan nuestra apariencia?
¿A cuántos nos avergüenza
quitarnos la ropa delante de nuestros compañeros
y cuántos vamos a permitir que ese temor nos prohíba
disfrutar de algo tan importante
como la actividad física?
¿No nos beneficiaríamos todos
de estos baños unipersonales?
No podemos cambiar de repente todas esas mentes transfóbicas,
pero podemos darle a todo el mundo
un espacio donde cambiarse
para poder llegar al trabajo
y hacer de este mundo un lugar más seguro
para todos nosotros.
Gracias por su atención.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.